no issue is hotter right now than
Republican tax reform between competing
House and Senate versions of legislation
the country is set for the most thorough
going and consequential changes in taxes
since the late 1980s to get a sense of
the good the bad and the ugly of tax
reform I'm sitting down with Grover
Norquist the longtime leader of
Americans for Tax Reform and arguably
the most influential activist on the
issue over the past 30 years especially
when it comes to lowering taxes Grover
Norquist thanks for talking with reason
okay so when the Senate passed its
version of tax reform you wrote this is
big a bigger deal than Obamacare big job
creation big middle-class tax cuts big
changes in an app dating in an outdated
tax code what do you like about tax
reform as it's shaping up generally what
are what are the large share on tours
there are things that happen immediately
and then they're secondary effects we
eliminate the double the tax
deductibility of state and local taxes
okay it's a pay-for rates go down
broaden the base and that's in both the
House and the Senate in the house and
the Senate they're the same $10,000 you
can deduct up to 10,000 notes of
property tax at the state local level
but not income taxes right they go okay
that's lower rates broaden the base who
cares what you just did was dramatically
remove an incentive for higher taxes at
state local level and so this reform
package is going to result in a thousand
tax increases that didn't happen at the
state and local level and a thousand tax
cuts that do is California with a 13.3%
top income tax rates gonna have to take
that down but California is also a net
donor to the federal government so are
is this gonna kill the Golden Goose if
you know California is a high tax state
but you know when people are wealthy
they're they kick a lot of money into
the federal government shouldn't they be
getting tax relief from the federal
government no okay because it is
California senators and congressmen and
New York senators and Congress and New
Jersey senators and Congress and
Connecticut science and congressmen who
vote for the very high tax rates at the
federal level
which is why those states are donor
states they also have politicians at the
state and local level who have high
taxes as well they damage the country
when they raise our personal income
taxes for everyone in the country but
they also damage the whole country when
their state politicians have high state
taxes that are subsidized by being tax
deductible by what what are the other
tax expenditures or or tax breaks that
get lost here that that you're good
about the the Senate version doesn't do
anything with the mortgage interest
deduction so it allows homeowners who
and the people who take the humph
mortgage interest deduction
overwhelmingly wealthy they can deduct
up to a million dollars or interest on
loans up to a million dollars for two
houses the House version caps out at
five hundred thousand for one which is
better and why shouldn't it be zero for
me well I think we should take it to
zero some of these things are how far
can you get any three senators could
kill the whole project so there are
limits to how far you can go and any
twenty five congressman can kill the
whole project so when you begin to push
around the edges and we call it pretty
close in both cases we we had one vote
two votes to spare in the Senate and
maybe 1015 votes to spare in the house
and now we're going to do this again so
given the rules we were living under
just the Senate rules the bird law okay
and the fact that we have narrow
majorities this is a very good piece of
legislation but that's a caveat it's not
what you and I would write if we'd wrote
it down it's not what I'd like to see in
20 years or ten years talk about the
corporate side of this because in a lot
of ways I mean the corporate stuff is
permanent or you know a no obviously no
tax decrease or tax increases ever
permanent really but what what excites
you about the corporate side of this
okay this is the driver of economic
growth the other reducing taxes on
individuals as a question of justice if
you earned it you keep more of it but
the rates that we have the 35% business
tax rate for corporations used to be one
of the lowest in the industrialized
world
now we're the highest in the
industrialized world the whole
rest of the world was up in the 40s and
the other down in the very low 20s we're
gonna go from 35 completely
non-competitive socialist China's at 25
we're at 35 and we think that there's a
difference between us and them there is
we're stupider
okay so our 35 goes to 20 now that may
bounce around at 2021 as they do final
negotiations but basically 35 to 20
we're going to be competitive with the
rest of the world I really like Donald
Trump's idea of going to 15 and I
believe that it's and I can assure you
that as soon as this bill passes I will
begin whining that 20 is not as good as
15 there is also the shift from a
territory from a global tax system to a
territorial one explain what that is and
why that significant that's the second
big deal the first big deal is that
investment income from around the world
will flow to the United States at a 20%
rate that won't at 35 companies will
move to the United States at a 20
percent rate when they were moving out
some 1,700 companies left got bought
move the paradigmatic case or a
newsworthy case from a couple years ago
was when Burger King was bought an
American company that was originally
based in Miami was bought by Tim Hortons
another fast-food restaurant based in
Canada and it out get away how
embarrassing
okay to lose one to Canada that's the
one to the north so one of the
challenges we have is the high rates
that's going to 20 big deal the other is
going to a territorial tax system most
of the world's territorial almost
everybody has a territorial tax system
in France France taxes French people in
French businesses in France if you set
up a French business in the United
States or a French person goes over here
and runs a rock and roll band the United
States tax them and when they want to
take their lovely money back to France
Frances nice to have you and your lovely
money here no tax no penalty no French
taxes on money you earned overseas as a
person or a business we fix that problem
for American companies overseas and we
say when you earn money in France or
Britain they'll steal some of it
but you bring it back and it's yours
we're not going to touch it again so is
this going to resolve you know we hear a
lot of stories about places like Apple
and perchik
having a lot of profits that are parked
offshore now they can come it back
without either paying competitive tax
rates or no tax on stuff that's already
been taxed yes it there is somewhere
between three and five trillion dollars
of American earnings overseas three is
what most economists at least say that
they believe is out there five is the
number Trump likes he may be right
because we don't know we're not sure but
three that he does have many known a
documented penchant for exaggerating
this is trying the size of his hands to
the size of his crowds okay we'll
probably go with three somewhere between
that's a lot of money to come back
pretty quickly then both bills or both
versions also take some action against
the individual mandate for Obamacare
does that matter in this at all and I
guess it's the what is it the Senate
bill gets rid of it and the House bill
reduces the penalty to zero or something
like this yes the house is also agreed
that they're going to take the Senate
right so why is that important in terms
of tax reformers that's just kind of an
extra you know it's a cherry on top both
it's a very large chair it's a huge
chart it is as big as any of the other
things that we're doing getting rid of
that tax when it's a tax it is a tax on
you if you refuse to buy Obamacare or
insurance and and it's seven hundred
bucks for an individual but goes up and
it's two thousand dollars twenty four
dollars for a family of four it is a big
number three million people get hit by
it eighty percent of them are in less
than $50,000 a year
so this attacks on low-income people
that the Washington Post loves mmm okay
all the left-of-centre structures
newspapers magazines pundits who like to
say that this is a bill to help rich
people they most want to keep the tax on
low income people who don't want to buy
out one of the most controversial or
most talked about because it seems kind
of like you know it's it's not gonna
raise much money but it doesn't
convenience a lot of people there is
discussion that and I in the House
version that things such as graduate
student tuition scholarships you know if
you went to graduate school and you get
a TA ship and you get free tuition which
costs a thirty five grand a year
you're gonna be paying tax on that as
compensation which makes go into
graduate school much more expensive is
that a good thing or a bad thing it's an
interesting question that what they're
trying to do is even out because if you
were to do this in any other business
that would be taxable income unless it's
healthcare yes and frankly and we're
trying to call those down and bring down
rates this is one that sticks out we
have particularly vocal people who
benefit from it I mean there's an easy
thing to do you know don't pretend to
charge don't charge them for the
education and don't pay them for the
other you can do both and the
establishment has written themselves
lots of benefits in tax law over the
last sixty years this is one of them
okay
the tax deductibility of state and local
taxes advantages public sector unions
who say go raise the money it's easy to
do because it's tax-deductible it's like
giving to charity it's tax-deductible
which should be zeroed out
I believe self do ya know you take these
things step at a time you don't want to
get too far ahead of where the country
is to understand it a lot of people feel
if you didn't have tax to tax
deductibility for charity there wouldn't
be any I don't think that's correct I
think if you look at the history charity
goes up and down with people's incomes
not with tax rates or some of these laws
or tax deductibility but I understand
the fear that people have on that so
let's take the stuff down a step at a
time as rapidly as you can and move
towards where the government doesn't
advantage any behavior or disadvantage
anyway if you're just steals what it
needs to run some of them do you do you
feel compared to I mean Americans for
Tax Reform you created that in 1985 yeah
so it's a little bit before the the last
big tax you know truly comprehensive tax
rate and white house to do the 86 bill
and they asked me to run it so I was
only coming in to my kind of political
consciousness and fayefaye and I I'm not
sure that I've fully gotten there yet
but it seemed like there was much more
of a national conversation about what
was you know what was the goal of tax
policy what were the effects of tax
policy that you know he was bipartisan
bill Bradley the New Jersey Democratic
senator was heavily involved in it
there doesn't seem to have been any kind
of discussion like that here it's it's
mostly like a grab bag of okay we can
get this done this done and this done
and we need a big win we meaning the
Republicans do you feel like there isn't
a you know isn't a consensus or a
clearly articulated rationale for what's
what's being put forward as tax rate one
there's a complete consensus on why
we're doing this within the Republican
Party okay this is the same process as
86 without the Democrats invited to the
party and that's not exactly correct the
Democrats have invited themselves out of
the party when we started this process
all but five of the forty eight
Democrats wrote a letter saying to hell
with you we're gonna have nothing to do
with anything that's a tax cut okay
we're doing a tax cut so goodbye and so
they decided they weren't gonna be in on
the process 86 was unique and not
something that can be replicated for a
number of reasons first was an 81 the
Reagan came and cut marginal tax rates
all across the board the country was in
a recognized recession it was hard to
argue it wasn't the continuation of all
of Jimmy Carter stuff we cut taxes
deregulation what about let's not piss
on Jimmy Carter completely he was not
such a bad guy
no on deregulation he and Kahn and a
couple of his appointees were very very
good and they don't advertise that they
took a lead on [ __ ] if you ask them what
you do and your president he knows
unless that is one of the things but
it's true that Kahn helped got that ball
rolling FTC and so on and then Reagan
got the legislation moved as well to
make it permanent
dramatically changed things I think
Reagan's economic growth was half
deregulation half tax cuts but the press
can only focus on tax cuts that
understand deregulation it's a thousand
million different decisions in different
places and you can't put it on TV but
you can do guy signs bill on TV and they
can understand that 81 we cut taxes
Teddy Kennedy said it would create
inflation inflation went down to almost
nothing and to give us a recession or to
prepare we're also tax increases after
that before 86 yeah there were there
were these reductions across
rates just kept coming down so the
Democrats were so wrong on the rates and
the fact that you would actually get
growth and more revenue even out of
lowering the rates so by 86 they said we
don't want to be on the wrong side of
the tax issue - we know if we cut the
rates we're not gonna lose any money and
we want to get all that lovely money
from getting rid of junctions and
credits Republicans said someday the
Democrats will be in power they'll take
away all those deductions and credits
and they leave the rates where they are
so let's trade the rates for those
deductions and credits before the
Democrats can just take it all okay so
each team for their own reasons was
willing to go to a revenue neutral rates
down eliminate deductions and credits
revenue neutral led to all sorts of bad
things on growth because some of the
deductions and credits they got rid of
were part of the growth pro-growth
agenda long depreciation schedules
instead of going to full business
expensing immediately but it was
progress because it simplified the code
and it did give you the lower rates but
then you had stalemate for the rest of
that period this time around the
Republicans Democrats say they want
lower marginal rates on businesses but
for eight years of the Obama
administration they never wrote a bill
they never did it but here you know in
the 90s then you had Bill Clinton coming
in and he raised the top marginal income
tax rate and a lot of people predicted
okay that's the end of the you know
Reagan expansion that wasn't true
towards the end of the 90s Oh towards
the end of Bill Clinton's years he cut
capital gains rates substantially or you
know and I mean all of this stuff that's
a political process and that worked out
extremely well so why wouldn't the
Democrats come around at all this time I
mean how much of this is just a way of
talking about polarized politics that it
doesn't have anything to do with the
issues it's just we're in a particularly
tribal period that well one it's tribal
but it's it's more than that it's tribal
but by belief and when Obama was asked
why wouldn't you cut the capital gains
tax you know you raise revenue if you
cut the capital gains tax and you could
help poor people with that lovely money
and he said that he would rather leave
the capital gains tax up even though it
hurt lower-income people even though it
got the government less money
there is recent poll that said one out
of six people would would like to raise
taxes on rich people even if they
thought it would hurt the poorest people
so one out of six people united states
is the caricature of the left which is
they hate rich people so much they don't
mind poor people suffering but now in
terms of total revenue you know which
ultimately is what you know what we're
talking about here you know taxes are
not the price we pay for civilization
they're the taxes we pay for government
yes we've been pulling in for most of
the 21st century it's it's gone up and
down a little bit particularly during
the recession but about 17% of GDP
regardless of what the you know what the
actual tax code says you know is why
does it matter like I mean do you and at
grover norquist who likes lower taxes do
you want the government to be making you
know taking a bigger bite of GDP now as
taxes so that was letter U is this going
to lead to are we going to stay at 17
percent of GDP but we're going to have a
bigger economy so we have more money to
play with or my target is that
government spending as a percentage of
the whole economy as a percentage by ATP
should be as low as possible
okay that's and you can drive that down
in one of two ways you can either grow
the economy and leave the same stupid
government the same size but it becomes
just a smaller problem if you've grown
the economy twice as big government's
half as big as the rest of us that we
can jump it when I look at but the other
part of that is you could shrink the
site you could have the same size of the
economy nothing gets any better but the
government strikes well that's better
too so I want both and that's what this
bill gets to more growth and overtime
less spending how does it get at all to
less spending though and this is I mean
what I want to get real about here is
and you're famous probably your most
famous quote is that you want to shrink
the size of government small enough
where you can drown it in a bathtub or
somesuch
yeah what are the Republicans doing and
this I think is you know from a
libertarian perspective I remember very
clearly the Bush years where Bush was a
small government conservative who
somehow between entering office and
leaving had grown real federal spending
inflation adjusted terms by 50%
refused to pay for wars with war taxes
which is a traditional thing that you
know presidents would do or call for
every time the Republican Party at least
in the 21st century has been in power
they have tried to cut taxes sometimes
successfully sometimes not Bush
certainly did cut taxes a bit and then
they just blow out spending and the
Republican Party is you know if you look
at the house plan if you look at you
know Donald Trump's budget plan if you
look at when the Senate kind of gets
around to talking about this they want
to go from spending about four trillion
dollars now to five trillion dollars in
ten years
where are the spending cuts Donald Trump
has pledged never to touch Medicaid or
social security now
you just okay you put your finger on the
answer to the previous question but you
you needed to listen more carefully to
Donald Trump which is not always what I
advise somebody to do but in this case
Trump is said during the campaign when I
get touch Social Security pretty easy
promise to make sense it takes 60 votes
by law to do anything we have 60 votes
to the wouldn't touch Medicare which i
think is a mistake but I understand the
argument I don't need this headache you
know I don't need to Medicare and Social
Security that's an increasing percentage
of government spending but here's what's
on the table and here's what happens in
April of this year okay not in some
far-off time April of this year we're
going to do tax cuts that's the
reconciliation package this year passed
in December of 2017
April 2018 we're gonna do welfare reform
well welfare TANF is a very small number
mm-hm we're gonna add food stamps a very
small number
well 75 billion ourselves it's not too
small and we're gonna add in Medicaid
which is a quarter of all state local
budgets mm-hmm and take those together
and probably also what's left of Obama
care in terms of spending and Block
Grant those to the states and limit
their growth to below the way it's
growing now okay so that you out ten
years or whatever ask peter ferrara what
the numbers are and it's he says in a
matter of twenty years it's it's
trillions of dollars that you get just
from taking rate down a little
the same token Medicare and Social
Security spending are going to go up
there already effectively running a
deficit so we're gonna need more taxes
if we don't change their benefit how do
you eat an elephant one bite at a time
okay well and so these but if you do
this and make it work and I believe you
can we did it with welfare reform with
with Clinton with Clinton this is what
we're going to shove down the Democrats
so we're going to is also George Bush
who helped expand you know food stamps
disability etc you know who expanded
Medicare okay who you know they did No
Child Left Behind Chuck actually
surprised the United States right George
Bush spent six years being the mayor
back yet and he couldn't be bothered
being president states so what he Trump
do to change spending from you know in
his first budget to a second budget he's
not he's not cutting spending
he will say oh I'm getting rid of like
I'm cutting this small agency here but
he's not touching it the budget was
pretty good you can't get it through the
House and Senate his budget was better
than the house is that because the way
you reduce the size of government in the
United States and a republic is you
reform government down
you don't chop at ten percent you reform
it down you change the rules you block
it out to grow Walker and out to 50
states and then some states do it really
well and some states do it really poorly
and everyone says let's do more of that
and the country shifts that way and
spending actually came down rather
dramatically on the welfare aid to
families with dependent children TANF
they focused on people who needed it and
states will police fraud because once
you but so that when does when does
Medicare and Social Security and defense
spending which are the three biggest you
know items went you know when are those
gonna come under review I believe that
once we can go to the American people
and convince them that this was done
properly
that you can look at Medicare and and
take the project which was a bipartisan
project not just too long ago that Paul
Ryan and and Democrats came up with now
Democrats all ran from it as soon as
they thought somebody would actually
pass it but we do need to have you can
either keep prices down through price
controls or through competition and they
try and do it through competition rather
than price controls which is why sir
the Senate joint Tax Committee has said
that their scoring of tax reformer the
Senate plan is that it will increase
national debt which is already depending
on whether you talk about
intragovernmental like the total
national debt or just the debt owned by
the public but it's already at you know
historic highs and at the the total
national debt is over a hundred percent
of the economy they say that the Senate
plan will increase that by one trillion
dollars if you include economic growth
1.6 trillion without scoring it that way
do you think that that doesn't that's
wrong or that doesn't matter or two
things I think it's a ridiculous number
if you grow at 3 percent a year instead
of 2 percent a year and a year ago we
were told you couldn't grow at 3 percent
any more because the new normal is 2
percent the same Club for Growth limits
to growth argument that was made to
justify four years of Carters failure is
now used to justify eight years of
Obama's tax you can't grow any faster
than that anymore there's nothing but a
lot of conserve I mean you know when the
Republicans is mounting debt a problem
because there are no projections really
that show national debt as a percentage
of GDP or spending is going to be going
down anytime soon
Republicans spent a lot of time when
Obama was in office saying you know
mounting national debt is it I think
it's a drag in the economy and they were
actually aping what Democrats were
saying under George Bush Obama himself
in 2008 when he was running for
president said we got to get the debt
under control I mean isn't this all just
kind of like kabuki BS theater of like
when you're in power you say national
that's a bad thing
or when you're out of power it's a bad
thing when you're in power you run it up
because everybody likes it and isn't if
taxes are the price we pay for
government shouldn't we insist as you
know from a fiscal reality we should be
paying full freight for government at in
every year no but the the challenge we
have is that both parties use the word
deficit and neither mean it Democrats
say we're worried about the deficit we
should raise taxes and the Republicans
say we're worried about the deficit we
should cut spending
so the public hears in Ross Perot but
then we never do anything we do cut
taxes and we do increase spending I mean
if you on a personal level if I you know
this is like government buy Groupon if
you can get a dollars worth of spending
for 75 cents you're gonna probably want
more spending if you were spending a
dollar if we were actually fully
expensing the cost of government
wouldn't we wouldn't the demand go down
cetera therapist I fear not because one
things government does is very well they
hide attack they corporations will pay
the tax they put the tax into products
they put the tax into regulations
instead of taxes it doesn't even show up
on the books then government is very
good at hiding its true costs for just
the reason you said if people understood
how much government costs they wouldn't
want as much right but the government
gets to play at this game too and they
get to hide how they impose costs on the
American people but we need to take
taxes down to get growth we need to take
taxes down because it's your money and
it belongs to you the idea that we're
somebody who's running on saying we're
giving all this money to people the idea
that the government fails to take your
income they've somehow given it to you
that when you pass a mugger on the
street he gave you as what your wallet
you know oh my he gave me a wallet no he
didn't he forgot to steal it he didn't
give it to you well it is but it's also
wrong I mean for the government say if
you own a house and you make enough
money where you make sense to itemize
your tax deduction we're gonna give you
some money back that we're not gonna
give to a renter isn't that wrong I mean
that's unfair it taxing is taking money
from people who earned it and giving it
to people who didn't necessarily writ so
fairness is an odd concept in dealing
with taxes
there's destructive taxes there's equal
taxes there's less destructive taxes
fairness is that there's always struck
me as the wrong word to think about with
taxes a quick final question when will
the you know what when will the tax
reform be signed by Donald Trump and
will you be happy with the results I
will be happy because this is a huge
step in the right direction
I will then immediately begin to whine
that we've got further to go and start
in on next year which is the entitlement
reform and literally trillions of
dollars in in reduction will cut more
than nine trillion dollars over the next
20-30 years wiping out all the build-up
under Obama because unfunded liability
is debt so and we thought we need to get
rid of the unfunded liabilities of
Medicaid Social Security that is as as
much debt as banked debt that's just
debt that hasn't arrived yet it's coming
unless you change what you're doing so
will tax reform be home for Christmas
tax tax reform will be here for
Christmas it will give you significantly
more growth than we have if you go at
three percent a year for a decade
instead of two percent a year for a
decade the government Nets two and a
half trillion dollars you can buy a lot
of tax cuts for that all right we'll
leave it there we've been talking with
Grover Norquist he's the founder and
president of Americans for Tax Reform
Grover thanks for talking to Reid thank
you
[Music]
you